if you're going to build something big  it's not you doing everything it's you  hiring people to do things and you're in  charge of the following framework hire  fast if they prove to you in the first  three six or 12 months they stink fire  faster if they prove to you in the first  three six or 12 months they got it  promote fastest more than anything I do  in my life I've been wrong in hiring  it's just a hard game but the reason I  built massive companies is because I  have fired faster in my older age  because I really struggled with it in my  youth and now I'm promoting fastness for  the last decade and it's been game  changing winners like to be seen and you  trying to hold it off because you don't  want them to think they're too big of a  winner like small businesses listen I  get it every dollar house I can wait a  year before I promote and the money if  you got a winner lock it in